l'enquète de la semaine concerne le cas
laetitia hallyday une nouvelle fois
cette semaine la jeune femme fait parler
d'elle au sujet de la sulfureuse affaire
d'héritage qu'il oppose depuis près de
deux ans aux deux aînés de johnny et
cette semaine la sphère a pris une
ampleur totalement inattendue qui
redistribue totalement les cartes suite
à un retournement de situation
incroyable
en effet alors qu'elle semblait
déterminé à mener à bien la guerre sans
merci contre laura et david pour
l'obtention de l'héritage mardi dernier
elle a posté sur instagram
un message qui a laissé de nombreux
internautes s'en voit accompagné d'une
photo en noir et blanc du couple
laetitia commence voilà bientôt deux
années que mon monde s'est arrêté de
tourner deux années de douleur si
profonde deux années sans mon âme
plongée dans un deuil c'est difficile
elle évoque ensuite ces vies qu'elle
soit protégée avant d'expliquer qu'elle
n'est pas responsable de cette situation
nombreux sont ceux qui m'ont tenu
responsable des dernières volontés de
mon mari il est temps aujourd'hui
d'éclaircir et d'apaiser dans un
dialogue constructif et serein
les incompréhensions et les querelles
qui ont maintenant trop duré c'est là
qu'elle annonce la nouvelle qui a secoué
internet
je choisis la paix c'est avec cette
volonté que j'ai donné dès aujourd'hui
instruction année conseils pour toute
démarche procédurale à suivre
effectivement quelques minutes plus tard
ses avocats annoncent que laëtitia a
décidé de retirer la demande en appel
qu'elle avait formulée auprès du
tribunal de nanterre une décision lourde
de sens qui offre un avantage
considérable à laura et david dans cette
bataille juridique
autres éléments complexes dans cette
affaire d'héritage géniale idée avait
une dette colossale de plusieurs
dizaines de millions d'euros envers le
fils
alors selon vous les derniers
rebondissements peuvent-ils tout changer
c'est tout vous dire parce qu'on a fait
beaucoup de choses cette semaine en une
semaine tout a bougé et letizia ne
ferait pas appel de la décision
utilisait que la france finalement que
johnny était français tout simplement et
c'était donc à au territoire français de
décider de l'héritage et non pas le
trust américain on a appris également
qu'il avait une dette assez énorme et
enfin enfin fait le total du patrimoine
de johnny il devrait avoir aux antilles
de 33 millions d'euros de patrimoine
mail à 30 millions d'euros de dettes au
fisc et on a aussi appris selon un
maître perez maître roland perez qu' il
n'aurait pas et il aurait peut-être été
sous sous influence lorsqu'il a écrit ce
fameux testament qu'il serait du coup
peut-être pas valable voilà donc ça fait
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de choses
donc déjà pourquoi est ce qu'elle ne
veut plus faire appel ça devait être là
en mai finalement donc du coup il y aura
pas à cet appel pourquoi est ce qu elle
l a décidé de ne plus le faire sur des
réseaux sociaux elle dit que ça y est
elle veut la paix son mari est mort
depuis deux ans et que maintenant elle
veut la paix et on sait aussi que tous
les avocats se sont vus il ya dix jours
maintenant pour trouver un compromis et
sortir de cette situation pourquoi est
ce qu'elle veut elle veut plus faire
appel parce que de toute façon
ses avocats ont dû bien lui expliquer
qu'ils avaient très très peu de chances
qu'ils gagnent cet appel ouais donc est
là elle est en train de tendre une main
mais voilà elle essaye de passer pour la
gentille je veux la paix mais c'est
parce que l le père croit un compromis
alors qu'en fait elle a perdu voilà donc
il ya sûrement des négociations mais
maintenant qu'on apprend la dette
colossale qui a que johnny doit au fisc
et que son patrimoine n'est pas si
énorme que ça mais non donc il va pas
rester grand chose ça va être plutôt
pour se battre pour le droit moral il
restera pas grand chose je pense une
fois que la maison de marnes-la-coquette
est vendu tous les actifs qui peut qu'il
peut y avoir en france
il restera rien de très important
commandant figure mais je donne la
parole aussi à catherine connaît bien le
sujet mais guillaume vous avez m perez
oui et c'est très important
effectivement de comprendre qu'on ne
parle plus aujourd'hui c'est plus passé
qui est en gros ce que m'a dit roland il
est roland perez irain que le passé ne
comptait plus vraiment aujourd'hui ce
qu'il fallait c'était défendent le droit
moral parce que le belge est vrai que
vous faites en sachant qu attention il
est l'avocat de sylvie vartan oui ok
donc il dit lui sa théorie c'est que
sylvie laeticia hallyday se doit
absolument récupérer et garder le droit
moral parce que sinon elle n'aura plus
de raison d'être il faut qu'elles
puissent continuer à participer pour le
futur le fus c'est quoi le droit moral
le droit moral c'est le fait de pouvoir
dire on va faire ça avec les oeuvres de
johnny ou le rhône
nisc veut david aussi et c'est légitime
que le fils devait aussi parce que sinon
elle ne sera plus que la veuve de johnny
hallyday y aura pu avoir deux parties
dans d'antan et concours il va se faire
et qu'on comprenne des appétits m'en
dédis le droit moral c'est important
parce que c'est l'argent va arriver
maintenant du futur les olympiens à tout
ce qui va sortir sur johnny le passé
bête bouffer par le fils salah nouveau
bond dans le passé post bac mais bon le
fou le futur est ce qu'on a bien résumé
cette histoire déjà catherine owens
c'est tout à fait ça mais moi je me suis
toujours quand il ya une décision comme
ça quand laëtitia tend la main ces
quelques jours quelque chose derrière
c'est de façon sûre c'est que c'est à
peu près un mois que les avocats ont
repris langue et d'essai discuter et
effectivement elle fait pas appel parce
que le juge avait tellement bien un mode
notifié et expliquer vraiment de la
décision que c'était pas contestable
alors est vrai seulement perdu en appel
par contre un petit piège en effet c'est
par rapport à la dette au fisc en tant
qu'épouse elle n'est ce sont les
héritiers elle ne va pas payer à des
toffees quels sont les enfants qui m'ont
payé et les enfants et sont solidaires
entre eux et c'est à dire que pour
l'instant les enfants capes est plié
c'est david et laura et ça c'est un vrai
souci
ensuite deuxième ça dure que les 30
millions d'euros de dettes pour
l'instant reviennent à double hic pardon
ils sont solidaires entre eux comme
laura n'a pas d'argent c'est david
howell concret cas c'est un problème
tournure garde à vue tous la trentaine
d'euros c'est paradoxal quand on sait
que david est quelqu'un qui est qui
règle ses impôts rubis sur l'ongle qui
n'a pas une dette il se retrouve à gérer
des de son père c'est un petit point en
marche la peau sa tête d'autant que je
vous rappelle que davie c'est le seul
qui a hérité de rien puisque la partie
de maison qu'il a eue de sylvie en fait
c'était l'appel alors que j'ai ma
commande pour les gens parce qu'on s'est
posé la question dans la loge
aujourd'hui la des maisons partout les
maisons achetées en suisse il ya des
maisons un baril l'aprilia m adria
marnes-la-coquette en france est ce que
le fils est en droit de dire voilà tous
les biens immobiliers dans tous les pays
du monde
je peux les récupérer pour me rembourser
non il va récupérer les maisons
françaises ces trois américaines elles
sont dans trust après ça on croit savoir
bras pas tous chômeurs américaine en
revanche saint barth et marne la
coquette peuvent être revendus pour sa
manière la coquette sachant que nous
aurons des durées unis
c'est parti mais à 35 millions d'euros
pour les ont ramenés à 15 millions en
suisse à une mesure mal nos colonnes
vous avez la ville pour une activité m2m
la rva pour claude est aussi maintenant
les revenus doivent pas toucher johnny
pas très vieux monsieur
c'est très intéressant ce que tu viens
dire que moyen un truc que je comprends
pas dans la soirée ses dettes elle
existe depuis plusieurs années
pourquoi le fisc n'a pas ponctionner
effectivement l'arrivée d'argent par les
maisons de disques mais on l'a très bien
expliqué on a très bien expliqué parce
qu'il passe des coups de fil à sarkozy
qu'il connaissait bien le ministre
l'intérieur 80 ans est passable de
connecter les vous l'avez dit derrière
cette histoire sordide se cache une
immense histoire de fraude fiscale et
d'exil fiscal dont pas laëtitia était
quand même un petit peu complices qui
sont restés ça pas mal était au courant
et ont toute impunité est ce que si
johnny était toujours vivant aujourd'hui
on murray que la marelle cet argent moi
c'est la vrai qu'à part lui réclamer pas
de son vivant mais je suis bien quand
même
mais tu as tout compris thual un prix
effectivement c'est un petit peu le
sujet nous on a 10% de plus ça tombe
tout de suite quand et johnny c'est
compliqué on va pas étouffer une star
comme johnny connaît le sujet aussi dire
que quand même avec cet appel que
laëtitia l'idée ne fait pas ce que tu
viens de parler d'argent et tout c'est
quand même aussi la fin de cette guerre
en la famille c'est à dire c'est quand
même afin de deux ans où ils se sont
insultés par les etc
ils vont pas de venir voir qu'ils vont
se revoir le mandat d'après closer et
vont se revoir après le collègue gentil
la presse thomas novembre tous les
avocats pour discuter ensemble et c'est
le message que les sétifiens est quand
même assez beau alors on dit aussi que
c'est parce que justement comme une
amoureuse du coup elle est sur un truc
plus dans le présent est là elle se dit
je vais arrêter déclarant j'ai envie
d'être un peu plus dans la vie et
arrêter de me battre est-ce qu'on peut
dire un mot catherine il reste quarante
secondes est ce qu'on peut dire un mot
de cette phrase de roland perez qui est
sorti de nulle part
il n'était pas en capacité l'été il
était sous influence influent rendent
influence pas rien quand il a
sensiblement si je prends des guillemets
être sûr vous pouvez saint esprit comme
vous l'êtes mathieu est sous influence
de quelqu'un donc il était probablement
sous l'influencé de sa femme
en revanche il était apparemment en
pleine capacité ont cessé toute la
nuance à leur tour également ça n'a pas
de valeur et on voit tellement bien
c'est que des listes dans l'es6
testament à chaque fois la part des
enfants des aînés étaient diminués pour
disparaître comme un tueur je connais
plusieurs de ses proches et ça faisait
des années que johnny leur disais dans
le privé qu'il avait l'intention de tout
laisser à laëtitia en 2011 c'est là
dessus que ça peu appuyé relents pérade
en 2011 il avait déclaré qu'il voulait
que tous ces enfants soient irrités
soyez rythme
david en orbite ou bi qu'il voulait que
diaby gère ses droits moraux
donc on voit bien qu'il ya là c'est
l'affluence ce sont les boudou on a bien
compris